[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
يا امير انشاء وكتابه التعليمات او
الاوامر
الحاسوب وغيرهم
وممكن نعرف على انها وزير التواصل بين
البشر
والاله
اي جهازنا
نحن اكيد في لغه او وسيله للضوا البيانات
واخيرا
[موسيقى]
كل
لغه البرمجه
يعني زي هذه اللغات البشره
فاكيد هيكون في قواعد هي
القواعد البرمجه
طيب نيجي بقى نعرف
استخدام
فهي اكيد عندك
اول استخدام بناء المواقع وتطوير
التطبيقات السؤال الاستخدام تطوير الالعاب
وسالف باستخدام تطوير تطبيقات
التطوير تطبيقات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الكمبيوتر
[موسيقى]
في اليوتيوب وغيره
طيب في مصطلح ثاني غير العالم
واللي هو الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
اول الاجهزه
ذات الذكاء البشر عشان يسالني المهام
[موسيقى]
وده كله بكملنا
عن طريق الاعلى نفسها يعني
المعلومات وتقوم باعمال للمعلوماتها
طيب
[تصفيق]
من فروع علم الحاسوب ممكن يعلموا على هو
سلوك وخصائي
الحاسوبيه عشان التحدية
[موسيقى]
طيب كمان في انواع
فعندنا ثلاثه انواع اول المناطق اللي هو
الاصطناعي طيب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انه يحاكي اي مهمه
لكن طبعا
[موسيقى]
باذن الله
[تصفيق]
طيب نحن
[موسيقى]
ازياء الاجتماعي
ات تقريبا وتكون بالاضافه
للايداع العلمي والشيء العامه
الاجتماعيه
طيب بعد ما تعرفي معنى
في اليه
واحده هنعمل الروبوت
[موسيقى]
ممكن
الان الانسان ايش
طيب
[موسيقى]
الاعمال مبرمجه
طيب
يا اما صيدا مباشره من الانسان
احضريه اشارات من برامج
[موسيقى]
واكيد
الرخامه
في مدارس العسكريه
والصناعه وارتداعه
يعني مثلا
[موسيقى]
وتعامل مع
الاستخدامات
الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طيب
انا بدي احكي لكم
كل شيء
كنت بحب اعمل
والاسره
طيب بعد كده انا تعرفت على
فكره
طيب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعدها
[موسيقى]
والذكاء الاصطناعي
والحركات والحمد لله تعرفها
[تصفيق]
طيب
[موسيقى]
من الان
والاسبوع الاخير
استقال المشاريع
والمشاريع
احسن من مشاهدات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طيب
واللي هو
بنعمل كميه
المشاريع عملناها الاسبوع البناء الذكي
مشوار المستشفى
التلقائيا عن طريق ممكن تبدا تتحكم على كل
الاجهزه دي
[موسيقى]
يلتقط الاوساخ او النفايات من الارض
دموعه من الروبوتات
بس بالنسبه
[تصفيق]
طيب
عباره عن سيلفيات
الخمسه الاولى
تصميم النفايات
للدراسه
وداخل الاسد
واللي فيها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخير يعني الموارد هتحلل
في مده معينه عشان تحول ليله
احنا ممكن نستفيد منه في الطبخ
عشان يتوف
في السله دي
غاز في المنزل احنا نقدر ننظف منه طيب
اول اخر
اي حاله
ولا كرتون
مراحل المرحله الاولى اللي بيتم فيها
تشكيل النفاياتي اذا صارت يعني اليوم او
في او
يعني
[موسيقى]
طيب بعد المرحله اللي هي الكبيره
راح يكون
في الغرفه دي
[موسيقى]
في المعادن
ورق سواء كانت
او ممكن
[موسيقى]
نستخدموا يعني في السماء
وببساطه
يستطيع انا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رساله لكل الناس يزيد انه يتابعكم
ويحبب النجاحات في اي مكان هو احبه
[ضحك]
شكرا لكم
ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]